at 13 years old
now
after aznar
confidence
ah
and it is that it is
but there is no case they
occurred
and
in the next e3 steal
well
because there is no money for
the school
why
or in
its current and not concluded that majority
bye
but what
ah
either
and that's how
the goalkeepers were for
ah
you've played
more
and help
for
and
not
good times
in the shadow of the year
and
[Music]
the informal
o
and
s
good
oh
and now
3 good
with all sense
and
ah
wow instruments
me
[Music]
goodbye
i
and 6-3 before
[Music]
uruguay
what is
salgado
white knight
another difference
and
or not
me
and for more than three decades
uy
let's see
before
the people
i
and
there is a practice
or
not they did not
make this
app Mr.
Perfection
well
they are not
and
yes
wow
to
3 it
exists that transit went down
franck ribery
and the tide
well
i
above his blood
on those seven rulers
and
m
yes
be very real
medium-low
well that's how
you are
here
is a soldier
not
to the water
in a lot  s cases of risk
and
others
[Music]
d
I
mrc
organic to the area
the activity
what's up
games
[Music]
in action tends to react
emery reports and salsa
is for less
I don't know what else
ah
but no thanks I'm going to talk to many
good environment
and
enjoy
good
use English
that yes of saints
and it is popular
the reinforcement guardiola center
I make an effort there is no event
the children
good
but woman
shows chronic aquino
we continue new
luckily
just say terminal keyboards
in fact
h
and
these institutions
is  free
bake to defend them include the fire
your baby
white
already sees like this the body of how fresh
mouth
and
there are engravings from 1969
or no
yes
the day
or
harvey
and
on him
authorities
keep
that is
javier a
and
the songs
the arians
me now
cool yes that  no
ah
so I am
so me
and
and they are volunteers
4th
for harvard
in acting efficiency'
for your church
good morning
rich
everything extra red
is averig  uar which one is serious
yes no
and the sound
and
oh
and more
julián and the sex of teaching
those people backwards
and explains
workers
and
not even linked well in that country
diverse
of any kind
good
oh
good guy and even churros
in the  period
yes
to from scratch
and well
the pas de deux
sorry
e
sanz
good
well it
has actions
you are
good
but what I am
then I want is property
omar what's
good me
ah
or
yes
I can be creative be
careful
because I like it
or
type  next to me
is more even if I bark because here in the
viewpoint on which the city
and they
are insane previous but to play from
here entity below
I like
release
well
today
[Music]
and now imagine
maybe
yes
and they have downloaded the sample
let's see
ah
blood  senate
i come from florence
i was wrong
and that
and things that no
one
more why
the mother of god man
baic
but we will continue to press
and
but for
uruguay always
do it
no
and
why also  well france
visualize
let's go
or
action well
damage
theft both phases
hate
I lose
friis
as
yes
the low strength
degrees
now
check
and pay and if it existed
yes
and do
n't even write
well
wells we do it
in threes
now it
's nothing
no
enrique subscriber  from the central peak
and here it is
good
for me so that its people from the region
and they
know
all the sun water
[Music]
about the powers
I am glad that it will be
formally
and from here
a truth
v
but do not miss
maybe
software
and now
to my house
I am
and
because he talks
yes
foreign names
and
but
expte
without the reports
of our
but above all
I was
in 2003
arias
I take the for health
hirschman sold them
yes
and
and back
in the to
mons
it's me
or
laughs
heh heh
ah
well
and
I exercise
that's why you have to
teach those 4
[Music] it
's true
and it
's
or
that same day
people who want more
no longer
and
oh
to study
ideas
as he
didn't write
in society
that's why
then
like this
now we usually live it
for chivas